The second major concept and evolutionary thinking is randomness.
It's the role of chance in evolutionary events
and random things are also referred to as neutral processes and neutrality means
selection is not operating.
Things are neither being selected or not being selected.
They're just neutral.
Yeah.
There are two general reasons for neutrality.
One is that many genotypes may produce the same phenotype.
That's because the genetic code is redundant because some DNA is not expressed
because some amino acid substitutions actually produce no difference in the
shape or function of a protein,
and because development is catalyzed.
The other major reason is that many phenotypes may have essentially the same
fitness,
so even if you produce a phenotype,
there is still another level at which randomness can occur or neutrality can
arise.
That can be either because that particular trait is varying in a way that makes
very little difference to reproductive success or because the impact on fitness
of a change in one trait compensates for that have a change in another trait.
Okay,
let's unpack those conditions.
Okay.
First,
the genetic code is redundant.
It produces 23 different meanings.
That is either a starter stop code on or coding for a particular amino acid and
it uses 64 triplet code downs to do so.
So just to take one example,
you can see here that proline is being coded for by four different codes.
So that variation is usually at the third position.
So all of the DNA sequences that are coding for proline are starting with CC.
Okay.
And it is the fourth position that can be different,
excuse me,
the third,
the third position and the code on that could be different.
Okay.
Then some DNA is not expressed.
Pseudo genes for example,
are genes that are no longer expressed.
Here we have an example of a pseudo gene,
uh,
in the chimpanzee.
This gene is functional in humans that is not functional and there have been
three different mutations between humans and chimpanzees and insertion or
deletion and a point mutation.
Okay?
So pseudo genes result from a gene duplication that's usually followed by loss
of function in one copy function is lost because the pseudo gene is not
expressed.
All of its nucleotides are then free to diverge at random is they mutate.
And so you see the,
in the pseudo gene,
there will be a buildup of genetic variation for mutation.
Some other DNA is also neither described a transcribed nor translated.
It's also free to accumulate mutations at random.
So although we've recently discovered that much more of the genome is functional
than we had thought,
there are still portions of the genome that are essentially free to vary at
random because they are not having impact on phenotypes.
So here's an example of what happens when a particular variant as neutral alpha
globin evolution in vertebrates has had many amino acid substitutions.
Down here on the x axis we have time and millions of years and on the y axis we
have the number of amino acid substitutions and each spot is a comparison
between animals that have been evolving over the last 500 million years and are
examined today.
Well,
we can see is that the line is very close to straight and that is what we would
expect if the rate of amino acid substitution is uniform and that means it's
occurring at random.
This happens in Alpha globin evolution because there were parts of the molecule
or an amino acid substitution makes essentially no difference to its function
and those are the parts of that molecule in which the randomness is occurring.
It is not occurring in the functional center where the oxygen binding is
occurring.
The next mechanism that produces neutrality and evolution is canalization.
The canalization of development.
Cannibalization is a word that means the limitation of phenotypic variation by
developmental mechanisms.
Canalizing mechanisms are those that resist the tendency of variation in either
genetic or environmental factors to perturb the phenotype.
You can think of them is buffering the phenotype against variation in genes and
variation in the environment.
Genes whose impact on the phenotype has been reduced or eliminated by catalyzing
mechanisms are then free or to accumulate neutral variation.
Then those whose impact is directly expressed,
so if development is sitting between the genes and the phenotype and is
buffering the impact of variation in the genotype on variation in the phenotype,
then the genotype is actually free or to vary.
It can accumulate more mutations.
Some of the traits that are canalized in tetrapods include four limbs,
two eyes,
one mouth,
five digits.
Genetic variation is affecting many things about these traits,
but it is not affecting their number.
Their number is catalyzed.
Now,
another reason for neutrality is that there is some phenotypic variation that
makes very little difference to reproductive success.
This is another level at which neutrality arises.
The population may be too small to establish a consistent correlation between
the trait and reproductive success.
That is a sampling issue or the variation may simply be irrelevant.
For example,
variation and traits that can't be detected by mates are pollinators are
predators or parasites or prey,
so it's simply can't be detected or variation that lies within the so-called
normal ranges of blood tests.
If total cholesterol is between 110 and 150 or systolic,
blood pressure is between 100 and 130 or diastolic blood pressure is between 65
and 85 anything within that range is not likely to be affecting reproductive
success very much.
Another reason is for neutrality is that a fitness gain in one trade can
compensate for a fitness loss in another.
If those traits are connected by a trade off,
if the compensation is precise,
then change will be neutral.
It could happen in principle with any tradeoff including more offspring,
less survival,
more success,
fighting for mates,
less resistance to disease,
more resistance than normal infection,
more costs of inflammation.
Those are all significant trade offs,
all involved with medical issues,
and if the compensation is precise,
then it's possible that you could have people with many different offspring who
had the same reproductive success because they had very many different
survival's
or more success fighting for mates,
less resistance to disease and so forth.
If the compensation is precise,
you'll get neutrality.
However,
the compensation is often not terribly precise.
For example,
in the 1918 influenza pandemic,
the mortality rate was highest in young adults with the strongest inflammatory
responses.
Their lungs flooded with fluid and many then died of secondary bacterial
pneumonia.
So this was a trade off between having a strong inflammatory response and a
robust immune system that would deal with most other infections but was
inappropriate for the h one n one variant they cause the 1918 flu epidemic.
That was a a new experience for the immune system and it resulted in a spike in
mortality
in people who are between about 20 and 35 years of age.
So we'll come back to this in later lectures,
but you can see that we have here both the percentage of people with pneumonia
in blue and we have the influenza related mortality rate in red.
The people who died were people who are at their peak physiological fitness in
midlife.
Okay.
So what are the mechanisms that cause random change?
There's mutation and the sense in which we Taishan is random.
There are founder effects in genetic bottlenecks passaging through small
population sizes.
There's the mundelien lottery,
the idea that Meiosis is a fair coin and there's variation in reproductive
success and populations of any size.
I've highlighted in red here the factors that contributed to genetic drift and
that will follow through the next couple of slides.
Okay,
so first,
what about mutations?
In what sense are they random?
Well,
there are several senses in which they're not random.
They occur more frequently at some sites than at others.
Okay.
Have you taken rate and pathogenic bacteria increases in response to certain
signals?
That is their mutation rate across much of their genome
transitions.
That means a puring to a pure green or a perimeter into a perimeter [inaudible]
are more common than trans versions of Trans version would be a mutation that
took a Purina to a perimeter thing or a permitting to a pure rain.
Your patients do not produce random change in phenotype space.
That means that mutations are only able to modify the phenotype that's already
evolved.
Now,
what is the sense in which mutations really are random?
This is the critical sense for evolution.
There is no systematic relationship between their phenotypic effect and the
needs of the organism in which they occur.
You tations are random with respect to fitness.
You're not random with respect to these other things.
Okay.
What does the second mechanism,
well,
the second mechanism causing random change or effects of small population sizes,
and let's take a look at things that experienced some small population sizes,
the Pitcairn islanders and other founder populations in humans and Cheetahs.
The founder effect occurs with just a few individuals,
found a new population with only a small portion of the variation that was in
the original stock and when that happens,
if there happens to be a mutation for a genetic disease,
it can suddenly occur at high frequency because you have a few people and one of
them has a mutation.
In the large population,
it might've been at much lower frequency.
Examples are the genetic diseases in Quebec,
Tay Sachs disease among the Afrikaner's,
that's Porphyria and on Pitcairn island,
which is diabetes
type one diabetes.
The other
population size effect is a genetic bottleneck,
so a population crashes to very small size.
This is not a founder effect.
This is the same population,
but it crashes to very small size.
Only a few illegals then make it through because there are only a few
individuals they can carry them.
An example is the homozygosity of Cheetahs,
which is confirmed by reciprocal skin transplants.
You can transplant skin between any two cheetahs in the world and the skin
transplant will not be rejected.
They have lost that much genetic variation in their immune systems.
Another effect,
it's quite important is that correlations decrease in small samples.
If selection is really there but it's rather weak,
then it can only be effective in a large population because in a small
population,
the correlation of reproductive success with the trait will just be eroded by
sampling error,
so things get noisy and small samples.
The third mechanism that is causing random change is the fact that Meiosis is a
fair coin.
It's a very interesting observation and it probably is the result of evolution
designing Meiosis to be absolutely fair about which Leo gets into which Gammy
that's expressed in Mendel's law of segregation.
If there are two wheels at a locus,
the probability that one of them we'll get into a given gammy is 50% exactly 50
50 in the long run.
The average number of successful haploid gametes per parent in a diploid sexual
species is too.
That's because in the long run,
populations are stable and organisms are just replacing themselves.
If there just two chances and two flips of the coin,
then
on average individuals we'll just replace themselves in the population.
Yeah.
The fourth mechanism causing random change is that the treat or the gene lands
at random and families of different size.
Okay.
That is actually what we mean by random variation in reproductive success.
If an illegal randomly lands in a sequence of families that have different
numbers of children,
it will increase or decrease at random and frequency,
so that is what we mean by a zero correlation with reproductive success.
This producer's genetic drift,
it's the random aimless wandering of frequencies of neutral genes.
It resembles the Brownie in motion.
A small particles that are being pushed about by the thermal motion of molecules
and it is driven by the lottery of Meiosis combined with variation and
reproductive success.
It fixes neutral,
Ilias faster in smaller populations,
but it occurs in populations of all sizes.
Genetic drift is not confined to small populations.
It's going on all the time.
Yeah.
So what happens to neutral deals?
Well,
most of them never make it to high frequency.
Those that do get fixed in the population take longer to do so in larger
populations.
So if you're thinking about the dynamics of random change,
a lot depends on how big the population is.
Large populations,
however,
also have more mutations.
You can think of.
The size of the population is being a net out there to catch you tations because
the more genomes there are,
the more times a mutation can occur.
This exactly compensates for longer fixation times.
So well it takes longer to fix a neutral video in a bigger population.
There are more mutations arising in that larger population which are generating
neutral variants and drifting through to fixation.
That results in the exact compensation for the number of new neutral mutations
that will be fixed in a given time period.
So we don't know which mutation will be fixed,
but we do know how many will be fixed on average.
In that sense,
this sort of process,
which produces a molecular clock,
it's like an atomic clock that's driven by radioactive decay in any given period
of time.
We don't know which Adam will decay,
but we do know how many will decay,
and in fact,
that's so precise that atomic clocks are an international standard for precise
timekeeping.
Now,
in both cases,
the regularity emerges is the result of a very large number of independent
random events.
Just to give you some idea of how large that number is,
the Hathaway human genome consists of about three times 10 to the ninth DNA base
pairs.
That's 3 billion base pairs,
and one mole of uranium contains about six times 10 to the 23rd Adams.
So there are many,
many opportunities for random events to occur in both contexts.
If we go back and we look at the example of evolution occurring in the genome of
influenza,
we can see again this signature of a very straight line relating how much time
there has been for change to occur and the number of nucleotide substitutions.
So time on the x axis,
Nucleotide substitutions on the y axis.
These are influenza samples that were frozen and then sequenced later.
And we can see that even though population sizes fluctuated and fluctuated
enormously because these things have gone through epidemics and then they've
crashed and they've gone through epidemics again,
substitutions were regular.
Yeah,
the effect of population size on the number of new mutations
per generation.
Exactly.
Compensated for the slower rate of fixation of neutral mutations in larger
populations.
So you can estimate time from the number of substitutions.
The point about this being not being influenced by population size is important
because it allows us to pick up a clear signal of how much time has elapsed even
though populations have fluctuated dramatically and you can estimate time from
this molecular clock.
So,
for example,
if I told you that the number of nucleotide substitutions and a new sample was
about 60 different from a base sample,
that would indicate that it had been a period of about 35 years that those two
were apart.
That gives you a molecular clock that allows you to estimate time to last common
ancestor.
So to summarize,
there are several reasons why variation in DNA and variation and traits might
make no difference to reproductive success.
Meiosis is like a fair coin.
The probability of getting into a specific gammy is 50%
the fixation of neutral illegals is like radioactive decay.
In neither case do we know which mutation will be fixed or which atom will
decay.
But we do know how many events will happen and that gives us a clock.
Genetic drift fixes neutral deals at a regular rate independent of population
size.
And the regularity of the fixation of neutral illegals allows us to estimate
times to last common ancestor by comparing DNA sequences.
Thus
random evolution at the level of the population,
which is micro evolution,
gives us a clock that allows us to put timelines on the macro evolutionary
pattern of relationship and to phylogenetic trees.